we are very excited about our next guest
Oscar nominated actor thank you very
much that's Stephen young for six
seasons of the mega hit series The
Walking Dead he was huge on that he
started as a beloved character Glenn
that was his breakout TV role now he's
starring opposite comedian Ali Wong in
the new Netflix series it's called beef
critics and fans are calling it the best
series of the year and I agree he plays
Danny a struggling contractor who goes
head to head with self-made entrepreneur
Amy played by Ali Wong after a road rage
incident now is this Feud escalates it
threatens to destroy their lives their
families their careers but then they
slowly learn they actually have a lot in
common this is a preview
I just want to know if
you're like
I don't know happy
what
all your hard work
paid off right
you're fulfilled
why do you care
I just want to know if I gotta get to
where you are
everything
nothing less
or just a snake a snake it's on tail
[Music]
where you see them going nuts Steven
young is also executive producer on the
show he joins us first on CBS marks I'm
looking at going Stephen they shouldn't
have played that clip so Cliff where you
just see them going nuts I mean because
it sort of grabs you right away honestly
I'm gonna try not to drool over you
anymore but I've never seen anything
like this on television the writing the
acting the storyline is phenomenal whoa
and it was also very educational to me
so tell us a back story about it for you
what it means yeah well I mean for me I
think you know Sunny alley and I we
really kind of connected in these sunny
sunny is the creator
I call him Sonny okay um we just really
connected on our shared experiences
sunny and I especially were coming from
like we're from the middle of the
country I'm from Michigan he lived in
Iowa and Texas for a while and uh we
grew up in the Korean church and we kind
of came together in that way and were
able to tell certain specific authentic
experiences that maybe haven't been seen
before and hopefully we showed that you
know we're all kind of all the same
we're all doing the same things we're
like Stephen but we're also we're
different but we're also very like I was
very Blown Away by the church scenes in
particular by the way you sing too I
didn't know you play the guitar
plays a guitar not like you man I
appreciate it but I mean just looking at
that I thought I see that was very
similar to the black church but the
anger of these two characters talk about
that the anger yeah I feel like you know
we're there's anger but there's also a
lot of Envy these days and I think that
might be what we're dealing with you
know I think we're constantly looking
over our own shoulders like looking at
what each other have maybe thinking that
like we wish that we had what they have
and turns out like we all feel the same
way it feels like I mean we're all
equally gross and beautiful at the same
time and I hope the show feels connected
that way but the show is awesome it's
called beef yeah there's some pretty
intense scenes and a lot of like the
viewers thinking would I do that I don't
know
[Laughter]
how are you able to get into that as a
human being I mean have you had beefs
that you feel like all right I gotta
walk away from this or it's gonna get
bad well you know that was that was
actually the part that was like
difficult on a personal level of just
like oh man how do I love Danny as he
does these despicable things that seem
despicable but then like you go into it
and you're like you know all of us can
be pushed down all of us can be put into
difficult situations living is not
easy it's not easy and
um I you know coming out the other end
of it you you know you see like we're
all kind of sharing in this yeah thing
and well that adage about hurt people
hurt people yeah really so important
that was so important and so true and
played out with just about every
character in this series right because
Steve I mean Steven I was only going to
watch one or two episodes no you can't
you can't I watched episodes here's so
one of the things as Gail points out her
people hurt people and each of these
characters on the surface they're not
likable but they are so complex and so
incredibly nuanced and when you learn a
little bit of their backstory even Danny
who's done some terrible things but
Stephen you have a scene and Gail
mentioned the church but you have a
scene where Amazing Grace is being sung
at the church and the camera just stays
focused on you and you go from ah maybe
I'll Stick Around to having this
incredibly
I don't know revelatory experience as an
actor I think we have a clip of that
because I just found it so incredibly
moving and I thought this is where he
wins the Golden Globe
so this is the scene
[Applause]
oh this is you play this is me but but
the scene where you start to cry right
during Amazing Grace yeah it's just so
what was going through your how did you
get to that point as an actor well you
know we that was an interesting scene I
remember going into the scene and um you
know Danny's meant to break down in
there and I didn't really understand
what might be happening there's a lot of
ways it could be happening but for me it
was like
I was watching them shoot everybody else
and I was very like talking to uh uh
Sonny and Jake our directors
um I felt ready I was like I'm gonna I
think I'm gonna be able to go there and
as soon as they turn the cameras on me
we isoed sound just for me and then all
of a sudden it was gone I couldn't
conjure it up and I was kind of like oh
no what do I do so I step back asked for
a couple minutes and when I came back I
realized that it's the fact that they
had stopped singing collectively
together that kind of like stopped me
and once everybody started singing again
I began to understand I was I was like
oh this is where Danny gets to
lose himself yeah he can still put all
this down you know there's a there's a
lot of you do other things I love doing
minari too there's a lot of secrecy
about your role your new role in the
Marvel franchise what would you like to
share what Secrets would you like what
can you tell us uh absolutely nothing
thanks for coming yeah
before we go Ali Wong was incredible
David show was incredible yeah because
you know it was incredible Sonny's
incredible you all should win every oh
thank you so much this is the most
powerful piece of art that I've seen in
many people I I hope at the end of the
day too like people just have a good
time because we just had a good time it
was it's it's crazy but it's also so fun
it is a good time we're talking like
very uh lofty stuff here but it's just a
good time we have other things to do
okay all right all right cool over you
all day that's a good note and done we
weren't into it that much
thank you thank you thank you the show
is called beef it's streaming right now
on Netflix run don't walk yes run don't
walk